this is what building a home on Mars
might look like this structure is being
3d printed by a robot and could one day
be the solution to housing on the red
planet now a trip to Mars let alone home
there is still a long ways off but a
eyespace factory the company behind the
3d printing system thinks this unusual
design and construction method could be
used to make more sustainable earthbound
structures - AI space Factory calls them
Terra and the first is set to open early
next year it already has a waiting list
to stay the night to learn more about
this futuristic interplanetary building
system we spoke with a eyespace factory
CEO and architect I'm David mallet I'm
the co-founder and CEO of a I space
Factory
recently you've been doing work around
3d printing both for a Martian landscape
and here on earth can you talk about
some of the technology that's involved
in that the building in space is
extremely expensive and it's the
launching of materials into space that
really cost a lot of money so our
specific solution was to look at
habitats on Mars which could be 3d
printed from materials that you find on
the Martian surface so you're not having
to launch materials from Earth are we
talking about the same 3d printers that
people use to make like plastic paper
wave technology-wise it's not entirely
different from the desktop 3d printer
because we're still printing with
similar materials actually it just
scaled up and it has to be mobile and
deployable and obviously operate in the
extreme environments so part of the
challenge here with the the NASA
competition was trying to make use of
materials on Mars and this new
technology that can turn that into a
feasible structure what were some of the
other parameters of that challenge the
system needs to be a like totally
autonomous and when we think about
wanting to send astronauts to Mars like
they get there they they kind of need a
place to stay once they arrive which
means that the infrastructure needs to
be built out in advance of human arrival
so 3d printing was one solution but to
do it completely autonomously so that
the rover could go in advance
basically build a house so that when the
astronaut crew arrives a habitat and all
the other infrastructure that you need
is already there can you describe what
these structures look like in terms of
color I think you know definitely will
have a Martian hue because the actual
material is the Martian rock we have a
piece of simulated Martian matter so
obviously this is not from Mars but it's
built this 3d printed from the materials
that we would expect to find on Mars the
Terra where we're definitely printing it
larger than the prototype be made for
NASA so it's like 21 foot diameter 24
feet tall 2-story homes have 500 square
feet it follows definitely in the tiny
home category the Martian habitat we
designed was about double that size so
it's a thousand square feet now the the
design itself is quite unique and if you
can take a look it has this egg shape
this is to optimize for the structural
forces that we anticipate on the
structure maybe our previous imagination
of what buildings on Mars might look
like is more like a dome or something
that's low-lying we found that it was
actually more efficient to build
vertically its shape is if I can draw an
analogy to a Coca Cola can because the
fundamental force that's acting on this
is the inside pressure is much higher
than the outside Martian atmosphere
which is very thin and so it tends to
want to expand so this shape is just
very very efficient at containing that
internal atmosphere how exactly does the
3d printer work when it's building a
structure it prints it layer by layer I
think the easiest way to describe it as
it comes out looking like toothpaste it
just sort of squirts out a nozzle it as
it cools down it sets and it becomes
extremely hard but it comes out kind of
like in this molten form so the
interesting thing is like we don't need
blueprints like in the traditional sense
of architecture we can go straight from
a digital model and you have a process
that converts the 3d model into a
language that the robot understands what
have we learned about 3d printing houses
from this experiment it seems like
building something similar on earth
might be you
here you would think so and you know
we're going through that process right
now so after we designed Marsha and
built a prototype for NASA we began a
project we call Terra so if you think
about you know the the whole concept of
3d printing on Mars with Mars material
apply that to Earth it's it's it's a
much more sustainable way of building to
be able to send a robot how to site
gather the materials that are there so
so that that's where the space
technology really has applications to
Earth now on earth we have to deal with
problems like rain and snow and things
that we're not gonna find offworld which
frankly we're having to go through right
now as we build our first Terra hmm
unique challenges on earth yes so now we
have 3d printing we have the ability to
print with natural materials
we're not restrained by form anymore as
we're developing the technology we sort
of rethinking the design as well so the
buildings that will emerge from this
process will look nothing like the
buildings that we've seen so far how
long does it take to build one of these
structures for Mars or for Earth yeah so
on earth I know that answer a little bit
more clearly so like you know Tara if
you were to sort of print it around the
clock we'd be looking at something like
200 hours when you're talking about a
Martian environment I think it's a lot
different because just the amount of
time that it would take to sort of
collect the materials right so it could
be a far longer process because you have
more extreme temperature swings I think
you also run into considerations there
so I can't fathom a guess but if I were
to throw out a number to be in the order
of months so it's not a super fast
instantaneous process the part of the
technology that's the least understood
at the moment is the sort of harvesting
of the natural materials and then how do
you process these things on-site and you
know so right right now a lot of these
steps are done in the lab or the factory
environment and what we're going to be
doing next year is taking the material
aspect of what we're doing and moving it
on to the field so on Mars you are
harvesting materials from the planet
itself how exactly do you turn that into
something that's a feasible building
material it's like pasta
if you've ever made pasta at home you
kind of put the ingredients in one end
and he turn a crank and it sort of comes
out through a die right so you make this
long strand of spaghetti from the raw
ingredients that it is about you know
raw ingredients how do you mix them what
temperatures do you cook them at that's
sort of really what 3d printing is like
actually it's about your raw ingredients
it's about your temperature it's about
your timing
we're like harvesters and scavengers is
just like taking what's there scavenging
the waste can you cannibalize the lander
itself and extract the materials from
that then you sort of take this line of
thinking and pull it back to earth and
you say well what are the natural
resources on earth that we can use and
yes there's like the rocks on earth and
the plants on earth we also have a lot
of garbage on earth so when you talk
about what is your potential building
material and it's it's going to be waste
you know and there's no reason why we
can't 3d print from plastic waste so
Tara will actually be about 50% recycled
plastic waste and then 50% biopolymer
we're talking about robots that are big
enough to build an entire house are you
developing these robots yourself like
what do they look like how do they work
our strategy is not to build like a
giant robot but to take a lot of robotic
systems and put them together and so our
main 3d printing robot is a typical
industrial robot that would normally
build a car and we're connecting it with
other other elements that move for
example when we're printing the Tara
we're printing it on a turntable so
we're spinning the print like a potter's
wheel and then we put the robot on a
forklift so that it can reach up to 24
feet high you're not having to talk
about giant machinery you can actually
talk about modest machines but as long
as they're given a kind of mobility
solution then they can begin to reach
all parts of the building so that's why
I think that there's no theoretical
limit in terms of how tall or how large
or how many you can build I'm sort of
reminded of the hype around 3d printers
themselves ten years ago when everyone
sort of thought you'd have these things
in your home and you would be able to
print anything you wanted and of course
that hasn't really panned out why do
think 3d printed architecture is
different you have over 300 people
signed up to stay natera over like 400
nights and because of the success of
that we're already talking with our you
know one of our customers that's call
them or our future Terrans they want to
build their own I think the interesting
part about it is the people that we're
talking to like how they bring their own
views to the table but everyone has sort
of like linked together by this greater
mission about you know wanting to find
more sustainable ways of living and
building on this planet so I think you'd
be quite interesting to see how this
evolves over the course of the next
couple of years mmm so believe the hype
but give it time to mature exactly let's
see this in the long term you know we're
in a business that when you talk about
the space it's extremely long term
horizons and 3d printed buildings is
something shorter than the space horizon
but nonetheless it's going to take time
until this is really like
cost-competitive and has scalable as
traditional construction but that
shouldn't limit us from starting this
because if we don't start it now there's
simply no way that we can build enough
buildings for growing populations and
rapid urbanization and do it in a
sustainable way so we need this new
technology it's an absolute must thank
you so much for joining us thank you
it's been my pleasure